we're all human we all make mistakes
it's just that in this line of work the
consequences of those mistakes are
simply more consequential
but not you no mistakes no ma'am
not me
dr death really is an original take on a
true crime series
screw this is based off of the true
story of christopher dunsch
his behavior is almost unbelievable get
dorothy burke prepped for a craniotomy
you're going to be asking yourself how
the hell did this happen and oh my god
could this happen to me i'm sorry sir we
do not perform craniotomies at this
hospital
you're talking about drilling a hole
into her skull when i tell you to do
something
you do it it's really a story about
stopping a psychopath from continuing to
operate on people
but he was empowered and enabled by a
faulty system you are going to suspend
his license
we can't do that why the hell not
texas decided to reform its tort laws
which made it financially unviable for
lawyers to go after
somebody like dunch it's a system that
is pushing the resolution of the dunch
problem to the next county
you're still operating of course i am
why wouldn't i be after what you did
to your patients come back here again
and you're going to jail
my surgeries were perfect everyone
josh is everything you want in a
project's leading man
he had an emotional journey and people
are going to be
absolutely astounded by what he is doing
so there are no complications
i don't have complications miss michelle
shugert
teams up with dr henderson and dr kirby
and goes after a dunch christian's
character he's a maverick
no more half measures right henderson is
there to curb
some of kirby's ideas the system is
broken and we are a part of that system
the one thing that i really would like
audiences to take away from our series
is that there are also heroes in the
world still
we have to make sure the dutch never
operates in a hospital in texas ever
again
there are brilliant people out there who
are sacrificing their own lives putting
their own careers
on the line in order to protect us every
day i'm gonna sit here chatting we're
gonna do something
you